good evening and thank you for joining
me
i'm here to share the latest information
we have
about the new omicron variant and how it
may affect us here in wales
it's been just three weeks since the
first cases of the new variant were
identified in south africa
and since then it has traveled around
the world
it is here in the united kingdom and it
is here in wales at the moment the
number of confirmed cases here is low
but they are growing every day
we have to be prepared for cases to rise
quickly and very steeply
just as they have in other parts of the
uk
we're still learning about this new form
of coronavirus but all the information
we have tells us we are facing a very
serious situation
by the end of the month omicron will
have become the dominant form of the
virus in wales
bringing a new wave of infections and
illness
this could then translate into a large
number of people needing hospital
treatment just at a time when the nhs is
already under significant pressure
this welsh government will do everything
we can to protect people's health
and to keep wales
safe
now over the weekend new evidence
emerged about the effectiveness of our
vaccines against omicron
two doses of the vaccine is simply not
enough to give the level of protection
against infection we all need
the booster dose is vital
we have already increased the speed of
the rollout of our booster program
new clinics have opened and operating
hours have been extended
but urgent efforts are now underway to
accelerate the program even further
so that we can offer all eligible adults
an appointment by the end of this year
if at all possible
but this is a huge undertaking
it will be the priority for our nhs over
the coming weeks and please
make getting a booster your priority too
it is the single most important thing
you can do to protect yourself against
coronavirus and this new variant
i want to thank our vaccination teams
for their hard work hard work to protect
us all
the health minister will provide further
details about how we speed up the
booster program at her press conference
tomorrow morning
none of us wanted to hear the news of a
new coronavirus variant
after almost two long years of the
pandemic we had all hoped that we could
put coronavirus behind us this christmas
unfortunately we are once again facing a
serious and worsening situation
but we have faced challenges many times
during this pandemic
and we've learned from each one
we can once again
pull together to look out for each other
for friends family and neighbors to
protect each other
and to keep ourselves safe
and well
already steps have been taken to
increase protections in wales and we're
likely to need to take more steps to
keep wales safe
if we need to do this then of course i
will keep you updated
please
stay safe this christmas
diorjo gallon ichigid